jetzt geht ein sozusagen einen
notfallplan los der schon lange lange
fest steht da gibt es ein ganz klares
protokoll und wir schauen uns mal an wie
diese operation jetzt abläuft
das passiert bei der operation london
bridge der todestag der queen wird als
die welt bezeichnet
in den stunden nach dem tod der königin
werden der premierminister kann binet
sekretär und weitere ranghöchste
minister und beamte über eine anruf
kaskade informiert ihnen wird der coach
ahnden bridge ist down mitgeteilt dann
wird das nichts auf eine offizielle
mitteilung herausgeben um die
öffentlichkeit die flaggen in whitehall
werden auf halbmast gesenkt zur gleichen
zeit findet in der st paul's gesiedelt
im herzen londons ein gedenkgottesdienst
statt der premierminister und eine
kleine anzahl hochrangige minister
werden daran teilnehmen
am tag nach dem tod der königin kommen
um 10 uhr morgens hochrangige
regierungsvertreter im st james palast
zusammen um den neuen könig in heutigen
prinz charles zum herrscher zu erklären
am zweiten tag nach dem tod der queen
wird der sarg in dem buckingham palace
gebracht am dritten tag nach dem ableben
der queen wird der neue könig seitz in
der westminster hall
kondolenzbekundungen entgegennehmen am
nachmittag begibt er sich dann schon auf
eine reise durch das vereinigte
königreich
am vierten tag nach dem tod der
monarchen wird charles in nordiran
eintreffen wo er im hillsborough castle
weitere trauerbekundungen entgegennehmen
und an einem gottesdienst in das
spirituelle welt teilnehmen wird
zeitgleich findet eine probe für die
operation leyen statt die prozession des
sarges von buckingham palace zum
westminster palace an tag 5 findet die
prozession vom buckingham palace zum
westminster palace auf einer feierlichen
gute durcheinander im anschluss wird es
einen gottesdienst in der westminster
hall geben danach wird die königin drei
tage lang im westminster palace
aufgebaut und zwar im rahmen einer
operation mit dem codenamen
wir sagen mit 23 stunden am tag für die
löwen
zehn tage nach dem ableben der queen
kommt es dann zum staatsbegräbnis in der
westminster abbey stattfinden wird und
die mittagszeit werden landesweit zwei
schweigeminuten eingelegt
[Musik]